you
[Music]
the historic city of Bath in the West
Country a world heritage site
internationally famous for the hot
springs that provided its name
today bath who voted remain in the
referendum is set to be one of the most
hotly contested seats in June's general
election after crunching the numbers
bath looks like the perfect Lib Dem
target seat they'd only need 5% of
conservative voters to switch in order
to win here and the city has a history
of turning yellow before 2015 it had a
live demand P for 13 years both here and
nationally the youth vote could be
all-important so I came to this student
halt
to see if I could get any clearer sense
of how this constituency might vote if
the under 25s mobilised I'm interesting
what's in power come back within this
and what he suggests here and see you
happy about pork dental milk i fact
labor before mainly and but I'm just a
little bit nervous about Jeremy Corbyn
stance on it within the leadership of a
party moment how are you planning on
basing I feel about Pataki pretty sure
that conservative odd I office across
typically consulted future anyway but I
tend to vote for so clearly it's not
much clearer there then and from the
Conservative candidate a refusal to be
anything other than resolutely on
message I think we have to deliver the
strongly stable government our
constituents need is desperately to
deliver as well as what our country
desperately needs and the only person to
deliver that in my mind is treasom a and
I'm hearing that on every single
doorstep by going knock on the immediate
obstacle that the Lib Dems here have to
overcome is the lack of a local
candidate but once that's resolved they
believe that they are in with the chance
to win back this seat we're very
optimistic about the future we have had
over 150 activists and volunteers over
the past four days which is we're
breaking record numbers the amount of
people coming through my office door and
the amount of people and we've had
helped him in a recent by-election where
we've got 48 percent of the vote in the
Tories coming third is only boying in
our spirits and weighing really heavily
on the tour
priests throughout the city so yeah
we're hopeful but the only time we'll
know is on junior nights
both remain a referendum and with a
history of liberalism is a perfect
target seat for the Lib Dems provided
they can sort out who's going to stand
if the much-vaunted fight back is to
have any chance of succeeding and they
need to get organized and fast so if you
Ridge Sky News both